the U.S is running low on artillery to
supply Ukraine so stocks are rebuilt
cluster Munitions will be shipped to
fill the Gap the Biden Administration
says the decision came after much
consideration
we recognize that cluster Munitions
create a risk of Civilian harm from
unexploited ordinance this is why we've
defer deferred the decision for as long
as we could
but there is also a massive risk of
Civilian harm if Russian troops and
tanks roll over Ukrainian positions and
take more Ukrainian territory and
subjugate more Ukrainian civilians the
Pentagon was at pains to point out that
it has received reassurance on the
weapons use from the zelenski government
we're working with Ukraine to minimize
the risks associated with the decision
the Ukrainian government has offered us
assurances in writing on the responsible
use of dpicms including that they will
not use the rounds in civilian populated
Urban environments and that they will
record where they use these rounds which
will simplify later demining efforts the
Pentagon claims that these cluster
missions have a far lower failure rate
than those used before however it
refuses to release the research upon
which that new figure relies the last
publicly released report says the
failure rate was six percent potentially
four bomblets that will fail to detonate
in each munition that can mean hundreds
of thousands of unexploited bomblets
littering the battlefield nonetheless
Joe Biden said there was no choice why
now
run out of ammunition last year the US's
ambassador to the United Nations
chastised Russia at the general assembly
for using cluster munition saying they
had no place on the battlefield and
violated the Geneva Convention those
statements were then quietly erased by
the U.S from the official transcript the
message now from the administration is
when Russia uses costume Munitions it's
a war crime but when the U.S supplies
Ukraine with classical Munitions it's
all for a good cause she ever tansi Al
Jazeera the Pentagon